we're going to begin with a growing
pressure on new york's governor andrew
cuomo to resign
after a long-awaited report detailing
numerous allegations of sexual
harassment
cuomo continues to deny that he
intentionally did anything wrong
investigators allege he sexually
harassed 11 women many of them young
and retaliated against at least one
staffer who came forward
now the accusations include unwelcome
and non-consensual touching
offensive remarks and sexual comments
our national correspondent that's tariqa
duncan has been following this story for
months
and joins us from albany as you know the
state capital of new york
tariqa good morning to you a lot of
people want the governor to step down
including president biden but he
seems he seems to be doubling down what
else do you know about the story
well for starters gail we know that the
governor as
it seems at this hour has no plans to
leave now this
investigation was led by two independent
attorneys that were appointed by the
attorney general's
office and it didn't just talk about
sexual harassment in this report
but it spoke of a culture that was
filled with fear and intimidation
that the report says allowed sexual
harassment to occur
and persist this investigation has
revealed conduct that corrodes
the very fabric and character of our
state government
the explosive 165-page report
based on interviews with 179 people
alleges new york governor andrew cuomo
created a hostile work environment for
women
the independence investigation found
that governor cuomo sexually harassed
multiple women many of whom were young
women
by engaging in unwanted groping
kisses hugging and by making
inappropriate comments
eleven women came forward and
investigators say they found all of them
credible
including a new york state trooper who
worked on cuomo's security detail
the report says he sexually harassed her
on a number of occasions
by running his hand across her stomach
from her belly button to her hip running
his finger down her back
and making sexually suggestive comments
our investigation revealed
that these were not isolated incidents
they were part of a pattern another
woman
identified as executive assistant number
one
said the governor groped her according
to the report in november the governor
hugged her and reached under her blouse
and grabbed her breasts while at the
executive mansion
i want you to know directly from me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
in a pre-recorded statement the governor
defended himself against all of the
allegations
the facts are much different than what
has been
portrayed the governor also showed
photos hugging and kissing people of all
genders claiming
that's how he conveys warmth i now
understand
that there are generational or
cultural perspectives that frankly
i hadn't fully appreciated
and i have learned from this i think
that the governor is in for
a lot of litigation civilly perhaps
something criminally though we don't
know that yet
cbs news legal analyst ricky clement the
attorney general was very clear
that she did her job her job is over
and it is up to any police department
any district attorney's office if they
see
any of these allegations to go forward
if they choose to do so
the leader of the state assembly a
democrat said
the governor is no longer should be in
office at this time and said that they
would move quickly as lawmakers to
complete
its impeachment inquiry meanwhile that
groping allegation is being investigated
by police
and the district attorney here in albany
has also opened a criminal investigation
anthony jerica thank you charlotte
bennett was the governor's former
executive assistant
and was among the first to come forward
and accuse him
of inappropriate conduct in her
exclusive interview with nora o'donnell
bennett talked about what justice would
look like to her
the new york attorney general said
multiple times today that she believes
you
and the other women mentioned in this
report what does that mean to you
it was extremely validating and i feel
vindicated
um it's been a long day but
i'm i'm proud to be a new yorker right
now
the governor said today that he accepts
responsibility
and that he's making changes do you
believe him
accepting responsibility means stepping
down
and not only is he not stepping down but
he's outright denying the things that
he did so i don't believe him and i
don't want an apology
it's not necessary it's fake and his
propaganda video was not only
uncomfortable and inappropriate but
downright weird
and unnecessary in addition to this
investigation that found that the
governor sexually harassed
multiple women they also found
that the governor and his aides created
a toxic
work environment that enabled sexual
harassment
is that consistent with what you
experienced it's
extremely consistent and i think the
environment of
fear the environment of humiliation
the idea that at any moment you feel
like you could either lose your job or
get screamed at
or you know it was traumatic
on its own so when the most powerful
person in the office
and also the most powerful person in the
state
acts inappropriately you think
why would anyone take that seriously or
think that i deserve any respect in this
office
gonna be an interesting situation for
the governor now who seems not ready to
resign at this point
no but it's such a steady drumbeat of
calls to resign that's why
i'm curious to see how all this is going
to play out but he insists
he didn't do anything wrong so he's not
stepping down but you've got the
president you've got two senators
i agree with charlotte bennett about the
video i'm really wondering about the
wisdom of that video i just don't think
that was helpful it appears they
were prepared for it and in a way i mean
we know from
reporting that the governor was
interviewed for 11 hours by
investigators i'm anticipating after
that he saw what was coming
and prepared the video and nora we'll
have more coverage tonight on the cbs
evening news